non merci monsieur le président monsieur
le premier ministre je souhaiterais que
vous même et votre gouvernement soyez
parfaitement conscient de l'extrême
gravité de la crise agricole que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
cette crise concerne l'ensemble des
filières d'élevage et en particulier le
lait et le porc
les éleveurs travaillent sans compter et
ils vont à perte
j'étais vendredi à leurs côtés en
bretagne comme d'autres lors de leur
rassemblement
j'ai pu constater le grand nombre des
personnes présentes
j'ai pu constater la jeunesse des
éleveurs présents leurs visages étaient
graves
ils comprennent que ce qui est menacé
c'est leur projet professionnel et même
au delà à leur projet de vie il faut
agir et agir vite il faut agir pour que
les éleveurs français soit à armes
égales face à leurs concurrents
aujourd'hui trop de charge financière
trop de contraintes administratives
s'abattre sur eux ce n'est pas quelques
subventions qui atténueront cela il faut
rétablir nos relations commerciales avec
la russie
depuis un an nous perdons un grand
client sur une décision politique dont
les éleveurs sont les victimes
il faut exiger davantage d'étiquetage
sur l'origine des produits de façon à ce
que le consommateur sache d'où vient le
produit qu'il achète
c'est vrai nous avons progressé sur la
viande fraîche mais rien n'a été fait
sur les produits transformés sur la
charcuterie sur les plats préparés
or c'est là l'essentiel je sais qu'il
faut bousculer quelques règles
européennes je sais qu'il faut bousculer
quelques intérêts privés
mais l'enjeu c'est la survie de
l'élevage aujourd'hui c'est l'urgence
c'est l'urgence monsieur le premier
ministre
alors ce que je vous demande c'est des
décisions rapides claires définitives
l'enjeu c'est la survie de l'élevage en
bretagne en particulier en france en
général
la parole est à monsieur c'est stéphane
le foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt ce
président est monsieur le député je
réponds mais vous le savez le premier
ministre à chaque fois qu'il a été
nécessaire a été présent en particulier
sur les deux plans d'urgence que nous
avons présentées que ce soit en juillet
et en septembre et les arbitrages qui
ont été rendus au delà des 500 millions
d'euros que j'ai évoqués sur les 300
supplémentaires ont été fait hier à
matignon
vous évoquez la crise et la profondeur
de la crise j'ai parfaitement conscience
et depuis un an
monsieur le fur chaque fois que cela
était nécessaire
et en bretagne et ailleurs j'ai essayé
de mobiliser l'ensemble des moyens
d'état et l'ensemble des acteurs pour
que chacun prenne bien la mesure les
négociations commerciales sont en cours
aujourd'hui entre les industriels et la
grande distribution le message est très
simple dans cette crise chacun doit
prendre sa part de responsabilité et
l'état a pris sa part et continuera à
prendre sa part de responsabilité
quant à la question d'étiquetage jugé
que vous avez évoquées
je vous rappellerai qu'après une crise
qu'on avait vécu avec les lasagnes de
cheval j'avais négocié l'origine des
viandes dans les produits transformés et
ce à quoi j'étais arrivé comme
conclusion c'est que les pays européens
n'ont pas la même
agriculture que la nôtre et que ceux qui
étaient prêts et que ceux qui étaient
prêts à un étiquetage d'origine
considéré que l'origine pour l'élevage
c'était l'abattage du pays qui fixait
l'origine de la viande ce sur quoi je
considère que la france est un pays de
naisseurs engraisseurs et d'éleveurs
avec des abattages et on doit défendre
nés élevés abattus et transformés en
france c'est l'objectif de viande de
france mais comme cette question
d'étiquetage est au coeur d'un débat et
que certains laisse penser qu'avec cet
étiquetage tout serait réglé
j'ai décidé d'écrire ce décret sur
l'étiquetage et de transmettre ce décret
à la commission européenne et à partir
de là j'emmènerai avec moi les
parlementaires
merci monsieur mordicus la parole est un
monsieur michel pirro